hello and welcome to this video I'm
playing fighting dragon now hi raining
no bullet writing new account right
that's got 120 blitz games in so it's
not entirely it's highly new people are
so taken aback by this move it's a
normal mainline yeah it's not the main
line which is d5 but this move has been
around for 20 years now so one yeah
shouldn't come as a total surprise goes
back okay well that doesn't seem very
ambitious maybe he does not want to be
ambitious yeah you know no yeah that
looks very very okay I can simply play
96 and take only 5 and be fine yeah okay
let's do that
it's a very that's a very simplistic way
of doing it I admit but one of the
things that you can actually learn from
playing such relatively simple openings
assume to handle those end games if 6mm
were transferred it not sure that I like
this so much I'm a little bit behind in
development so what is he thinking about
what Bishop g3 looks super normal
yeah I'm actually wondering how I get
this developed don't like this I dyed it
down I didn't play this well very
strange
you know then Bishop d6 maybe em now
that I that was good
maybe it's good night c4 could be better
than castling long but castling long
will definitely be better for him as
well yeah came so Bishop Bishop e6 I
wanted to suggest but um Knight a5 is an
annoyance against that
yeah really not not a game that I like
okay one for rookie seven
hmm lucky 7 I cannot I cannot even
prevent it
I can go like Knight g5 and then on Luke
is seven rook f7 but if I move the
knight it's got 96 coming
when it's really a pain
really a pain
you know I have to make a move I mean I
cannot just the city and they mean
okay look e7 King f8 rook c7 rook d7
rocked xt7 Bishop e7 Bishop takes g6
that is my that is what I looked at and
it is really just a pawn
I hear king of eighty can actually take
on f7 and then played Bishop takes g6
which is an immediate threat
ouch ouch yeah yeah II can take and
Bishop g6 but I don't really see
anything else I have a terrible game
yeah yeah
simple simple chess but good of course
you
I don't I don't know if that was even
the worst thing that could happen to me
it is very bad I mean I'm not trying to
claim and find him but maybe I know
maybe even had something better that I
wouldn't rule that out
they're just f3 is fine it's fine for
him mmm isn't any kind of play really
the rookie is ideally placed on the
fifth-ranked
[Music]
you're just trying to hang on for a
while
yeah he should win of course but you can
always try to try to fight
yeah yeah this is unfortunately super
easy to win it's not even possible to
pose any problem there was a really
terrible game I mean I hated this game I
mean this is just totally equal and then
I managed with the c6 f6 crap to get
into this terrible position ready yeah
maybe I should have tried to do more I
mean Bishop f4 is just not looking like
a good movement Bishop f5 something
normal it's probably just good anyway I
was thinking okay that just let's just
get to this equal position and be okay
and this is of course just equal but I
played c6 and f6 and - look yeah that
was bad even here you you don't you
don't get you don't get a pneumonias
development anymore which is going to be
very awkward yeah it does not have to
solve any problem at all but it's the
thing just very simple I mean I wasn't
really sure this is the best but it's
probably good enough it's not let's it's
the pawn but also the very bad pawn
structure that I still have yeah was
having slide holes which is probably
just me being over optimistic but it's
just that this is so well positioned and
I've got four pawn islands I don't know
I should probably do something more
ambitious like just develop a Marine
I've got perfectly fine development
this is what the engine wants to play
yeah yeah this is this is very okay
actually like this I have a pawn they're
only six but now I'm I'm very I'm very
well developed like here I get an idea
for even I was thinking d50 form and
this was just a bad idea to trade to
trade here and then get into this
position
ah okay thanks for watching